this is a production of Cornell
University
um
done here over the years so I gave my
PhD final Talk In This Very Room this
change the other direction back then but
otherwise
so this is this is familiar territory
for me uh
so
uh not a lot of data slides today just
so you know what's coming
um
so
people come from plan or do plant
science from a lot of different places
and I started early
so this is uh me and my mom and that is
the local botanic garden where we spend
a lot of time it was called Lynn Ace
botanic garden he found it it was his
teaching Garden in his research Garden
so it has a long history embodies of a
lot of bruising in boxing so but wait is
that you
oh
um yeah so there's mom so where's
well
so this is the Mr graduate students and
he's measuring photosynthesis study uh
ecotypes and at that time you couldn't
buy photosynthesis equipment you had to
design and build it yourself you
couldn't buy gross Chambers you had to
design and build them yourself
mechanical chart records I think
um so all of this is stuff to be
engineered as a graduate of students
um
and so I've lived in that research
environment from early on because the
grad students and spending his time in
the lab and so 18 years after that
picture was taken he was elected to the
National Academy of Sciences so you can
imagine that I was exposed to some
really good science and some really good
scientists even before I like
and so
that's the environment that botany that
I grew up in
um and dad had that approach that
you know it's the thing he wanted to
measure you could already buy the
instruments to measure it wasn't very
interesting
so anyway
we jump to Cornell University so I
showed up at Cornell University for a
few reasons as a graduate student
um so I wanted to uh
have a better shot at getting a job back
on the west coast where I grew up
everybody getting applying for jobs
there was already from California so
I wanted to stand out so coming from
another place that's going to be helpful
do you know how that turned out so
foreshadowing some other twists here uh
and the other one was the study plan
physiology that's what I really wanted
to do and Cornell's field of graduate
field of Botany I had a concentration in
plant physiology and that had 80 faculty
members eight zero numbers in just that
concentration fantastic and uh
and that was great that was that was
a very good situation so
um but
after I finished of course plant
physiology was no longer a trending
problem for biology so I ended up being
a little bit hard to find work as an
old-fashioned science physiologist as I
was starting my career
another part was doing basic science
that was all the work I had done so my
PhD work was on gravitropism figuring
out how the little heavy particles in
the polyamala there in the top part of
that they dropped to the bottom of the
cell but then so what how does that
result in curvature of the root there's
a lot of steps involved in between there
some of which we have since discovered
but
ended up
identifying a lot of Pathways of
electrical
currents passing through the roots and
calcium channels and calcium movement
both within cells and in communion cells
a lot of work's been done on figuring
out that the receptor and what's going
on but we're still a little mystified
about what's going on inside those cells
but that was my background and so when I
came to interview for the job here
um that corn Roots which is sweet corn
by the way uh showed that I really did
work on vegetables I didn't let them get
bigger than that
and so I'm going to talk about some
some people and projects that I had
through the course of the year so
when I started
um
I had an early graduate student named
Lauren Gardner we wanted to come up with
a good Master's problem one of the
things that had happened was that the
growth regulator E9 I was no longer
allowed to use stomachable crops you can
use it on normals but not on food crops
and that is to maintain uh shorter
statute so they don't stretch when you
grow them in these high populations that
you see Lauren working on there they
tend to stretch so the one that says
zero that one is a skinny stretched one
and then the treated ones are shorter
and stouter the way we want them the way
they would have grown
so
sigmotropism was something that we uh
we're familiar with and so it was a
matter can we make this technique work
for
uh keeping the plants shorter
and so
um and so the goal was to have shorter
plants but not smaller plants than they
would have been and so Lauren worked out
um you know what's the daily growth
increments normal what's the additional
growth increment that you get with us
that's caused by the stretching
um what kind of intensity of the
treatment is the plant sensing what kind
of frequency is there uh
there's a refractory time so when you
when you stimulate a plant that it says
fat you did something to me but then
there's a period of time that it ignores
further stimuli and so you don't
treating during that period doesn't help
so you want to wait for that period to
expire
again after that
um how long does the does it remember so
it turns out that plants grow at night
they figure out how much they were
treated over the course of the whole day
remember they sum up over the course of
the day and then Express
in the same night so we
were able to come up with
recommendations for exactly how much to
treat so that you don't do more than is
necessary but you get the maximum amount
and then you are doing the right our
right size of transplants when they're
sensitive we did field trials to
demonstrate that this didn't set the
plants back in any way
um
and then she went on to do more work in
figuring out other species that it works
on so like you can't do peppers because
they get damaged you could do cucumbers
but only for about two days when the
hydrocodile is in Long baby so uh you
got a lot out of that
it's not widely adopted because there's
some other things that turn out to work
well and that are easier to do but
Lauren has gone on to be a professor at
Cal Poly and she's served as chair of
that department a few times in
horticulturist who got a very big Act of
Horticultural program there so she
turned out that was a nice start for me
um
so another thing I got into early uh
here was working with buckwheat as a
crop and
totally by chance that this happened
that the
buckwheat Mill for the Eastern United
States in Kenyan and they've been trying
to get somebody to do something
um and uh
it it's not a Prestige crop let's put it
that way and
it doesn't behave like a field crop so
the agronomists
um look down on it and didn't feel it
was worth thinking of their time so but
Noah was having no luck with the Iran is
quinoa
and it's not really a hearty cultural
crop we tried to sell it you know it's
in Akeem those little fruits that are
teens just like strawberries
I ended up working on it anyway and some
of the faculty on my mentor committee
um thought I'd just be really stupid
but I got money and I discovered early
on that having money for your research
program really moves things along so
that was a selling point but because
nobody else was working on this I had it
all for myself and so I could figure out
how to do extension without doing a
whole lot of damage
nobody if I did a bad job nobody except
the buckwheat forever this weekend
um
and I could become the sofa sensei
so uh so there's this buckwheat research
Community around the world and I'm
actually somebody within that research
community and nobody at Cornell Harris
but
it's yeah it's been fun I gotta say it's
pretty special but it's it's actually
starting to come back there's interest
now so some of the things we did so it
has low and variable yield the yield the
average yield has stayed the same from
about
1890 to 19.
and so why is that well there's a ton of
reasons that there have been only one
reason they will fix there's a ton of
pieces
um but I was able to go through a newer
systematic identification of what causes
the loan variable yield here in New York
and so it's a cross-pollinated crop so
it's a pollen limitation is it how much
it grows is it partitioning
um is it high temperatures causing
abortion of the flowers so there were a
whole bunch of things that we looked
into systematically one by one and so
this is one of my few data slides there
are 20 bushels in acres marked on the
yield axis vertical axis that's where
you start making money and then the
x-axis is how big the plan is external
above ground dry matter and for a lot of
crops it's a very tight line the Harvest
index is pretty much the same all the
time the plants are designed to
partition to the harvested unit very
very effectively and you as you can tell
by the scattering this plot that's not
true for Buckley that it can it can do
very well but a lot of the time it
doesn't so why is that and another thing
is that when you make the plants bigger
they don't yield more the really big
plants don't yield well because
basically they're partitioning educative
growth rather than
to uh
reproductive growth
and uh
there's a lot of things that are
happening so pollination was the biggie
um that people thought that that really
you have to add bees and then you have
to do a bunch of things there so we
looked at at that and the bees do
deliver pollen
a lot
that buckwheat's kind of unusual it
turns out so the top picture there you
see some pollen grains on the stigma and
then the pollen grains are starting to
grow down the style what's remarkable
about this is that that is five minutes
after remain pollen again so they've
germinated and grown about a third of
the way down
five minutes that tells you something
about the pollen competition so it's a
single ovary fruit so the first pollen
grains reach the micropologists what's
happening down the the green thing in
the bottom
that's the micro that's the pollen tubes
heading into the micro pile uh in the
ovary so the first one is is desires the
that seed and we discovered that there
is such a thing as pollen competition in
uh buckwheat which was a Hot Topic at
that time so if so that the fastest
pollen is also the one that produces the
strongest project so that's that's all
accomplished so having a lot of pollen
grains racing at once
gives you better projecting
and as you can tell
if more pollen showed up five minutes
later
like the second B doesn't really matter
already lost the race right from the
get-go it's only that first load that
matters and bees don't deliver a lot so
that's I think a pollination issue and
we also happen to find that there's
sexual selection which was also a hot
topic that is to say certain uh pollen
donors
are preferred uh by the pollen receivers
uh and so they will preferentially make
progeny with some of the governor pollen
so
um
just like him
so it also looked at yeah so high
temperature plays the role daylanes
plays a huge role in determining whether
our history goes to see in certain
leaves so we've got a lot of
recommendations out in the concrete on
when to plan it how to plants
that takes a lot of the physiology into
our talents we also got to do extension
and so one of the first things you do in
extension is fine now but the grower
Community needs and it turned out with
buckwheat
recommendations were helpful but but the
grower
really needed was first of all Community
because it was such a
disrespected crowd
um that they didn't know each other in
fact they were afraid to admit to other
people at the diner that they raised
and so that it is really the the sort of
community of Growers that knew how to do
it was this whole thing it was really
quite a challenge
um and the buyers the companies that did
the buying they didn't have field reps
out there connecting the Growers
and Cooperative Extension didn't have
anybody out there uh for a while so they
so Community was really important and
the other thing was dignity it's okay
you don't have to be embarrassed
um
and so I started doing these annual
grower field days where they would come
out and we would talk a little bit about
what we saw the crop doing and then the
the most important thing I think is they
got to talk to each other and we got to
be buckwheat people together
introduction to
um extension that was really valuable
you and you start to understand how many
dimensions there are to this thing
obviously I had no training whatsoever
in but many of those things
um
unfortunately I have colleagues who know
what they're doing so I've been able to
um learn that part as well
and I can say one sign of progress of
this is when you drive around you'll see
well-regarded Farms plant buckwheat by
the road where you can tell where it is
and in the past those were always on the
other side of the head so yes I see
Chris naughty metrics of extension
success there you go
um
stop working
um so I want to skip on to another thing
I've worked on for a while that was fine
so I had a colleague Gary Harmon
um so he was reading fungi for better
bio concussion
uh
so this was sort of my mentor committee
pushing me to do more part of culture
and get out of that
pseudo-anronomic problem and so this was
an opportunity to do more of
horticulturally things so
um
so Gary had read
a trichoderma that's a
fungus-like thing that is a great bio
control it's it's a it's in every soil
um it's the first uh fungus that
colonizes compost so there's a zillion
strains a huge Community studying all
kinds of aspects
um but they had bred one that colonizes
Roots very very effectively in the lab
and so uh yeah you can see it on that on
the emerging
adventitious move there
and Gary is a great Enthusiast it's so
much fun working with him and so one of
the characteristics of this stream was
that it has greater rhizosphere
competence than any other strains
and prices for competency in six roads
on the roots so usually if you work on
the rhizosphere microbiome at all
you realize pretty quickly that it's the
habitat that makes that determine suits
their far more than what you add
the newcomers generally don't make it
and so we tested this in field
experiments and
um so the green bars and green line are
the colonization of the top of routes
that were inoculated and the yellow ones
are the native trichoderma flora and
what we can see is that there's a lot
more when you inoculate even when the
crop is growing so it's successfully
colonizing Roots which is remarkable and
that doesn't usually happen
um and the bar graph there is where we
looked at different
soil environments developed in a 17-year
at that time study at Rodeo
um where they've been using different
nutrient sources and really establishing
very distinctive
microbial environments particularly the
legend one and this is uh it was able to
establish on roots in all of those so
the native floor that out computed the
native Flora all the time so that was
really a first for being able to do that
much
then we got in uh graduate student
Astoria doctoral students and because
Gary had a company he wasn't allowed to
be an injury advisor or a graduate
student because there's the potential to
exploit Refuge so it's a serious concern
um
and so I was taught to my major advisor
and so she came straight from Iran and
started meeting with Gary and me and uh
it's not the second or third year we had
these great meetings to talk about
research plans and Gary would say oh you
got to do this and you gotta do that and
then I would say I don't know I think it
would be better if you do this instead
of that and and that's where we left it
so Fatima was in this situation of if
you were going to do something just to
please your major advisor who wasn't in
the cars that was not a possibility so
she had to figure out for herself which
of our wise words were worth uh
following up on and she did an awesome
job of that and so what she uh did was
really identify
that a lot of the oxidative damage that
happens when a seeds germinates when it
imbibes water
the membranes start to reform and all
the biochemistry starts up there's a lot
of oxidative damage there and especially
in a weak seed that can really
debilitate the scene and so she found
that when you start adding water the
trichoderma germinates at about 17 hours
that
biochemistry starts happening in the
seed in about 35 hours and the radical
comes out and around 55 hours and she
could cut several hours off of radical
emergence time with the trichoderma so
that's really incredible and then it has
other consequences later on
as the seedling grows and so this was
pretty good discovery of how to uh
how to try to Derma this particular
strain of trichoderma was actually
working to enhance plant growth and it's
now a commercial products there's a
whole company built around that product
and there's a second company built
around some of the successor strains
and uh so the cup I mean the
recommendations that came out of that
are pretty simple fun of course you have
to apply to dry seeds
sprinkling trachoderma spores or
inoculum around after the seed is
germinated doesn't really help it has to
be the right at germination to make a
difference and that's super important if
you think about how people use uh
microbial inoculants
um it's all over the place and this one
is very specific and the other one is to
expect more large plants but not larger
plants necessarily but it's the somewhat
weakened ones that are brought up to 100
or 110 something like that
um the dead ones remain dead so we
we're hoping for Resurrection uh
material that didn't get it
but that
um those are are very helpful for making
the product successful and when you have
something like that all these
biostimulants and microbial an opulence
and stuff there is a lot of snake oil
out there and
you see bigger plants some of the time
with all of them but which ones are
Lotus which ones could do something but
you're not applying them right it's very
it's a very tough environment and
if you just put this one on and measure
arbitrarily you probably see the same
thing but if you use it right it really
does what it's supposed to do
so then I'm going to swing over to cover
crops so this was
coming into extension so I was
originally hired as 100 research
um
but they wouldn't let us do that after a
while
you have to have a split appointment so
I took on extension as an official role
like hey I have to say who price was my
initial chair he was fantastic but
um making sure everybody knew how to do
extensions you gotta know how to put
extension that was not optional whatever
your appointment was
um
but I had gotten to know Carol McNeil
with Cornell Cooperative Extension in
Ontario County so I know we know pretty
well and she had gotten in with this
soil Health team that was starting up
and doing exciting things
um
and so I I worked with her to figure out
what are the real grower needs she
really say for all vegetable crops what
are the top grower needs that I might be
able to do something about and she was
saying everybody's asking me about power
crops but I don't have anything good to
tell them and you know the literatures
about California and Florida and who
knows whether that's relevant to us at
all so it's really a void of information
so not necessarily a research void but
that was a huge information need and
tying that in with soil Health was real
easy because soil health
gives you two prescriptions one reduce
tillage the other plant cover crops all
right so you get the prescription plant
cover crops what are your plans uh we
needed answers so great situation there
um
so I dug into that and I have to mention
Joe Shale came my way about that time he
had been a technician with Rosie
providenti and uh
um with dick Robinson who's a vegetable
breeder so Joe is a
neurologist uh pathologist
could produce seeds like nobody's
business amazing amazing skills but I
have to say his number one skill is
teaching me how to be level-headed so
everything was falling apart I said
let's just do one step at a time you
know be done when we're finished
and so it was so I I have to give him
huge credit
um you can see him
standing in a field here if you want to
know what happens if you plant broccoli
on the muck this is what happens when
you plant them
talk about having things go too
vegetative nitrogen doesn't use
we didn't try that
so this is
um so one of the first things I looked
at for cover crops is was buckwheat
because I knew it and it's a great
covering crop for weed controls weed
control is usually the number one issue
for Growers
um so one of the questions when you
plant it and so we did a whole mess of
sequential plantings every year is
different but it's basically how big the
plants grow at different planting dates
and we found that even in July were good
and
in August we're unreliable because it's
either too folded that primer too cold
with the back so we had a lot more
details of that but a lot of experiments
along those lines for developing
um
planting Windows
um and coming up with an algorithm to
help figure out all the uh
characteristics at the time so we could
actually
develop a map like this at the last
reasonable planting date for any
particular location this is now in a
online tool that Growers use that they
can put their particular Farm in and get
a lot more detailed data but coming up
with planting Windows like this one
thing that this map shows that comes
through for a bunch of other things if
you look over in like Iowa and The
Dakotas you can see that the colored
lines run pretty much
straight across but then you come up to
New York and you can't use latitude or
longitude or anything to estimate what
that planting date is going to be you
really do have to throw some
calculations at it and get an idea
um what's appropriate dates
the other thing was putting things in a
framework that was really useful and so
it developed early on a recommendation
guide based on information that was
available
and
um
it's centered around two questions and I
found this to be very helpful what's the
management goal because there are many
different potential management goals and
what cover crop fits the planting
opportunity best and that
um
the second one that lately I've started
saying news
the best player for that position when
thinking about it as a team member on
the management program
so that guide's been up for a long time
there are ones that have been part of
that serve the region so this idea has
developed a lot in the meantime
and this is a slide I use in just about
every cover crop talk because it it
turns out that it's uh Growers who know
how to do these things can have success
with their cover crops if they do all
the things that are required to get a
fast start all the things that are
required to have no gaps in the stand
and to know how to kill it on time that
means you have to know what on time
means that can be more difficult than
figuring out how to kill it once once
you know
but that's been a nice Paradigm for
doing
cover crop extension and then doing
research behind it to note what does on
time mean for different contexts what's
the growth stage of the cover crop what
are you planning to do next what did you
do before
um
what are you going to use to kill a
whole bunch of things that need research
so that you know what the answer is
and then
finally I'll run through the broccoli
stuff so
you've probably heard of this one way or
another uh this was one of those fun
problems that came along Mike Dixon's uh
was the vegetable reader he
read a number of things but he had
broccoli and and
he showed me this funny thing that was
going on that there were these uneven
flower Bud sizes and that is what
actually looks like in the summertime
here
sell that obviously
um
but it seemed like a small enough defect
that it could be face right uh
and it seemed to be associated with the
heat
and so I thought well that's that's a
pretty straightforward plant Development
question
should dig into that curiosity we'll see
where it goes
and
so it turns out that it it really is a
temperature thing uh it's really the
cool temperature so it's like chilling
our accumulation kind of a deal
um
and it happens very early so these
inflorescences are about eight
millimeters across usually the sensitive
stage has already passed when they're
this big so it's early in development
so we were able to identify that fairly
early on and that provided a screening
technique
if you had a lot of resources you could
make progress um reading for that that
trades
and we ended up digging into the
genetics so this is uh the I did a
sabbatical at UCLA we were able to do
some in-situ hybridizations that just
shows where the uh
the leafy Gene that is being expressed
in the various stages of developments
we thought that was going to be a really
important community that is sunshine has
recently demonstrated
not one of them not one of the most
important ones
um I had a grad student then Denise Deco
and if you went to Sushi's talk a couple
weeks ago this is kind of led into uh
The Dread he went into but we looked at
all the
um
determine the identity of the meristem
or the organs
and so they had just worked out a number
of those in arabidopsis and Denise was
able to work out their expression
patterns in broccoli and they're all
there and they all change expression but
not quite at the same time and not in
the way that you would expect based on
their functions in the rapid offices
and that kind of
what do you do next when you discover
that
you can't build based on what those
genes are doing so
we weren't able to take that further
again
managed to do is was really impressive
so then
um
another opportunity came along in 2009
the in the farm bill we've got the
special crops research initiative the
program manager for that was going
around telling people about it and you
said well honesty is a big complicated
problem that you've identified and that
you propose to do a complete solution
with a transdisciplinary team and we'll
give you big bucks to do it and
everybody says yeah right I'm supposed
to do that
um
but we ended up going there and um yeah
so this was uh right up in the New York
Times couple of years after we started
it so we managed to get some publicity
for that
um so my my
collaborator and deciding that we were
going to go for it uh it was Mark
Farnham so he's a broccoli breeder down
in Charleston South Carolina and he'd
been reading the for heat resistance in
Rock Creek because they have a lot of
heat down there obviously uh and was
having some success so he thought
we can we can read the broccoli that
will grow here
Montgomery identified that well the seed
companies don't care because it's not a
big enough market nobody's buying
broccoli seed in peace and The Growers
weren't growing roughly because they
couldn't get decent seed and the uh this
uh wholesalers wanted local local
but they couldn't find any anybody to
buy trucks I didn't weren't trying so
there are all these steps and so it
truly was a transdisciplinary problem
thick system we had to hit all of those
things
good you know the the old Chicken and
the Egg you have to have all of the
pieces in place before eating
so it's really fortunate to get Jill
Eccleston uh on to his uh
entomology PhD
um
she worked with me for 13 years on this
project to collaborator relations
um
keeping everybody going analyzing the
the reading progress and working on
metrics there and
as an intimologist also developing
current sensible and sex recommendations
uh
Philip Griffis proper reader in in
Geneva
so he's he's a guy that's up for a
challenge I gotta say Griff is a great
collaborator because he's come up with
an idea and now
can't be done stupid idea
and then he does it
then you had something else next to it
uh that's that's cool too that you
didn't think about it so fun to have
collaborators like that so we got we got
him reading free intolerance to
um
so this is
um about halfway through the project
this was the collaborator list so when I
say that Jill was managing collaborator
relationships
it's a big job
um so this was in genetics reading
Regional trials nutritional quality
economics farming extension and
distribution in retail it's a huge huge
group
so we did uh trials and new materials
for uh reading programs so we had uh all
but cicada olives reading commercial and
private I'm sorry commercial and public
reading programs were involved with this
trialing material trialing new crosses
seeing if we could make some progress
um
planting in the different potential
Windows when it's not too cold and it's
not too warm and we could actually get a
crop and can we extend that into that
too warm period a little bit
and uh
this is one of our analysis of
how things perform so each row is a
different growing environment each
column is a different uh hybrid and
green is good and pink is bad
so this is just for an overall quality
trait we were evaluating
um 15 different traits all together
um
and so you see the leftmost columns are
the varieties that were available when
we started the project and you see a lot
of pink there
and then the middle part for the early
releases
and
and you see these more green happening
there and the varieties that are
available now are towards the
um
right and there and you see a lot more
agree so that gives you an idea of the
breeding progress that's been made
so that's been quite a successful state
of America
um
so
and so Zach stem cell
was able to really look at the evolution
of broccoli identify where we're getting
broccoli from uh Pathways associated
with high temperature
uh
so he's able to
map for candidate genes
so each of those is a little chart of
the
different traits that we could find
um
regions that where the genetic diversity
is responsible for variation in that
trait
so feed uniformity which was our big
um beginning a chromosome three in the
end of chromosome four there's something
really interesting there to dig into
uh and he also saw that the
um
in comparing the elite hybrids with the
land races there are some regions where
there's interesting material that we can
bring in to the elite material
and so there
are successes that's a hybrid that's on
the market this year
there we go so
it takes us later so the
the second picture there was taken last
week so Mom and I are still going to
Botanic Gardens
um Andrew's gamble Garden in Palo Alto
uh very
spent some of the Procter Gamble Fortune
a beautiful place in Palo Alto so that's
where she is now
um
and uh so that's uh
very good uh
time I've had you know I mean I keep
telling people I can't imagine a better
job I got to do all kinds of things that
I thought were fun pursue interesting
stuff uh both scientifically and
socially that really feel like they
matter
found a lot of people that are really a
lot of fun to work with to do things
anyway thanks very much
you would have for early career
researchers yeah
I think understanding the environments
that you're in so uh and being able to
accommodate change very well so you know
I came to Cornell's study drought I
recognized quickly that it is not a good
place to study crowds
um I changed I changed substantially
there so making changes like that when
the environments conducive to something
different than what you're doing
is one and having but knowing how to
take all of your skills
towards towards a different goal like
that's
uh one of the really important things
for success and then what I've found to
be useful like I've described here is
really understand the problem well
and understand the mechanisms that
underlie the solutions you're working on
and then find very straightforward ways
to boil it all down so I've got years
and years of research against the seven
words I have three lines on the covered
products but that's another part that if
you can get
if you can tweak the conclusion of your
research project
uh to a wide audience so those are some
things that I think are are helpful to
think about relatively straightforward
they're not
yeah so you know we're trained to do
science and so focus on certain things
but I think as a career you know
reaching out doing things Beyond you
never feels important you've done that
yeah you kind of switched over a little
bit but could you say a little bit about
your work in Washington and yeah so your
sort of developing professional skills
outside of research yeah so
the work we do isn't for three right it
costs a lot of money to do the work and
they've done the math but at least for
Agri Tech our total spending is around a
million and a half dollars per year
it's a lot of money
fine giving us that out of the goodness
of their hearts they're expecting a big
return on that and uh
so you need to make sure that keeps
coming by reducing and people have many
reasons
um
to provide that and Congress is huge so
I started um
going to Congress and then training
people to go to Congress
to bring in uh
money for the Horticultural program so
the specialty crop research initiative
was a really big one that's become a lot
of money but there are other ones that
are coming along that were asking for
money for and being able to tell stories
about look at the good things that money
did give us a little more and we'll do
it in the morning
um that works really well and I I think
that's something that we all have to be
trained for if we're getting money we we
need to not just report back to the
department chair of course
uh or uh to the program leader at USDA
you really have to go all the way back
to make sure that that keeps coming so
Bruce you want to uh do you know any
Mike
sure uh Hey Thomas great seminar thank
you
um I've really been wondering what was
going on next door all these years but
thanks for uh giving me a great summary
um and for those of you that haven't
been to his office it's so well
organized just as well organized as the
seminar it's one of the cleanest and
brightest nicest offices I'd also like
so a comment and a question uh thank you
for being dgs and doing so much for the
Department for so many years
um you've just been selfless about your
work whether it's for the Growers of
Cornell or the department or the section
so thank you
um the question I have is about the um
the chart that you showed with uh some
possible chromosomal locations affecting
uh traits in the broccoli head do you
know if there are some groups that are
following up further to get down to the
gene level to develop markers for for
those traits but especially to associate
those traits with particular genes
yeah
I
said
a critical question in the uh in the
world of marker assisted selection or or
crispring
um and
in a very general sort of an observation
something that actually marked soils
clued me into this
early on uh
so
readers don't use physiologists stuff
very often uh
if you decide to figure out how to how
some particular phenomenon Works usually
the Breeders have fixed it and then you
compare the current fixed varieties of
the old non-fixed varieties
and then explain afterwards how they did
what they did so that's the normal
Dynamics I've had that in my mind uh all
along so what I saw happening in uh
broccoli is that neither Griff nor Mark
were using molecular markers for the
ingredients
um that it it's a really big numbers
game they're also selecting on
dozens of traits at the same time and
the interaction among dozens of traits
and that gets computationally impossible
in a very about your brain can do that
by looking at it so they were generally
using that technique
um we're seeing the seed companies are
are using marker assisted selection for
a very limited number of traits that
they need to get rid of fairly early in
the process
I will and so they are very much set up
for
High throughput
genotyping for
a small number of things but they didn't
pipe everything
um
so my guess is that in
in broccoli breeding it's probably going
to be more genomic selections and single
Gene stuff just because the traits and
the interactions are so complicated that
you have to select for everything at the
same time and that the individual the
single Gene things will not be that
important but knowing which
um where there's interesting variation
helps you develop the tools as far as
genomic selection so that that's my
guess of where things are likely to be
moving fast but based on what I've just
been seeing lately
it's good time for maybe one more
I got a buck requesting for you
if it was such I mean it doesn't matter
I love soba and I use it as a cover crop
but if it was such a bad crop and it was
such a why were they growing it in the
first place yeah wherever they're
growing up well it's uh
it grows well where you have
low fertility particularly low nitrogen
and that was pretty much the condition
so it was one of the major crops in this
area
um in the 1850s it was probably the most
common crop in the Southern Tier in
Northern Pennsylvania
remains very important in Eastern Europe
as
The Last Resort hasn't gruel food source
but
Last Resort on a regular basis but it
stays there but it's very it's driven
now in part it has interesting flavor so
that drives it but also because it's
gluten free you can get kind of that
rich flavor in a gluten-free grain
that's what's driving it right now
so Bruce commented on that it was
commonly used by Eastern European
immigrants to the U.S yeah
Market in New York City
was
it was feeding in the early 90s because
the first generation immigrants were
dying on it they were the ones that were
really sticking to it
fantastic well thank you so very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu